[Applause]
the lead back up to 20.
Moran behind the screen by Jackson
counters with a three
off the Jackson screen
here's Morant for three again okay lace
is another one this is crazy tons of
time right now they're saying with that
hand we know you're gonna have to prove
it well he's four for six Davis with the
follow the lead back up to 16. Moran
raising up and one with the shaw
she's now got 57 of their 80 points by
scoring and the Rangers pursue a
three-nothing lead over the Devils at
Madison Square Garden jaw elevates and
lays it in
[Music]
John with a crossover and the
left-handed finish that's got to be
frustrating to you as coach
and it again it may not matter here
but you know where that matters and
route to a Championship LeBron splits
the double got it blocked by Tillman and
jaw on the Fly literally on the Fly and
one
he's basically playing with one hand the
thing is swollen it's painful
he has been Russell lost the handle and
he turns it over
lead at 14. still time Morant got it
hotter than Fish Grease LeBron's a
trigger
he turned it over
and jaw is going to get the easiest two
of the night right there and looks like
he tweaked the calf muscle he's holding
his left calf and
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you